le marché des célibataires explosent ils
sont plus de 10 millions en france à
chercher l'âme soeur les moyens de se
rencontrer se multiplient de façon
réelle ou virtuelle dernière trouvaille
le dating market le supermarché de la
rencontre réservée aux célibataires
l'objectif est de trouver l'amour entre
les rayons le bilan des courses avec
nathalie et terre et marqué tout
le concept une fois de plus nous vient
des états unis on l'appelle le dating
market le principe est simple vous allez
vite comprendre il suffit de suivre le
panier m'ouvre des ménages et une soirée
pour les célibataires veuves des erreurs
sur leurs courses chez lui pas très loin
donc je me ferme en course aussi janet l
aventure est au coin de la rue pourquoi
pas espérer
un panier qui possède une housse mauvais
à partir de là donc les gens peuvent
facilement s'identifier
après ils ont libre choix de se promener
dans le magasin comme il comme ils
l'entendent et on leur suggère de se
retrouver un pôle d'encaissement
spécifique ou là c'est une caisse qui
leur est dédiée le jeudi soir pour leur
propre encaissements cerise sur le
gâteau le vert gracieusement offert par
la maison que ne ferait on pas pour
attirer de nouveaux clients il faut dire
que le marché des célibataires est en
pleine expansion aujourd'hui près de 11
millions de français vivent seules
divorcées pas encore mariée trop occupés
par leur carrière les raisons sont
multiples et le phénomène très
occidental pourtant la réussite d'un
couple reste pour beaucoup une fin en
soi d'où la multiplication des lieux et
moyen de rencontre laurent et patricia
vivent ensemble depuis deux ans après
avoir dialogué pendant plusieurs
semaines sur internet c'est comme ça que
ça a commencé sur tout d'abord pour
discuter au départ j'avais une attirance
pour lui alors que c'est pas mon type
d'homme en plus et que je l'expliqué pas
et puis en fin de compte belle alchimie
c'est fait un million et demi d'annonce
2000 nouvelles inscriptions chaque jour
en six ans net club.com est devenu l'un
des principaux sites de rencontres en
france les milliers de couples se sont
ainsi formées avec souvent la clé un
mariage ont pris un bébé quand vous être
sur netlog vous savez que les autres
personnes auxquelles vous allez vous
adresser ont la même recherche le vous
ce qui facilite plutôt que de s'adresser
à quelqu'un dans la rue ce qui n'est pas
forcément évidente
rapidité et efficacité à l'image du
fameux speed dating comment rencontrer
l'âme soeur en 7 minutes chrono mais
diront certains doit-on vraiment
chercher l'amour comment chercher un
emploi et le coup de foudre dans tout
cela